todas las personas imputadas por el
supuesto caso de corrupción conocido
como
qatargate y han abandonado la prisión y
se encuentran con arresto domiciliario
con brazalete electrónico la última en
hacerlo ha sido la ex vicepresidenta del
parlamento europeo la griega socialista
Eva kyli quien ha asegurado que se
encuentra muy feliz de abandonar la
prisión la justicia belga accedió esta
misma semana a que Kylie pudiera salir
de prisión y pasar a arresto
domiciliario con brazalete electrónico
al igual que el resto de imputados de
esta supuesta trama de corrupción no es
algo inusual que se utilice como
alternativa a la prisión preventiva el
último en salir de prisiones esta misma
semana también había sido el ex
eurodiputado socialista belga travella
quien asegura que sigue siendo inocente
la semana pasada también el supuesto
cerebro de esta trama de corrupción el
ex eurodiputado Antonio panzeri también
pasó a arresto domiciliario
este mismo ex eurodiputado a principios
de año se acogió a un estatus de
arrepentido para dar información
sustantiva a la policía durante la
investigación a cambio de beneficios
penitenciarios la trama de corrupción
del parlamento europeo creó un auténtico
shock en las instituciones mientras se
prosigue la investigación en la
eurocámara se han tomado medidas más
restrictivas y duras para evitar casos
de este tipo en el futuro